اهلا بكم اكد مسؤولون ايرانيون وامريكي ان
الجانبين ناقش في فينا الوضع في العراق
بشكل مقتضب قبل انطلاق الجوله الجديده من
محادثات ايران والدول الست الكبرى حول
برنامجها النووي وكان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي قد قال ان بلاده منفتحه على
ايران بخصوص اي افكار من شانها الحفاظ على
وحده العراق نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل ياتي انفتاح الولايات المتحده
للتعاون مع ايران في العراق على حساب
علاقاتها مع حلفائها في الخليج وما مدى
توافق رؤى ومواقف دول الخليج العربيه بشان
التعامل مع الوضع في
العراق
حرس الامريكيون على توضيح ان مباحثاته مع
ايران بشان العراق لن تتضمن التعاون
العسكري كما اكدوا ان واشنطن لن تتخذ
قرارات استراتيجيه دون تشاور مع العراقيين
وكان جون كيري وزير الخارجيه الامريكي قد
ربط التباحث مع ايران بشان العراق باظهار
طهران
استعدادا للقيام بما دعاه امورا تحترم
سياده العراق وح اراضيه وقدره الحكومه
العراقيه على اجراء اصلاحات وسط هذه
المواقف تثار تساؤلات عما اذا كان هذا
التقارب الامريكي الايراني يمهد لتغيير في
خارطه التحالفات الاقليميه وايضا عن
الرؤيه الامريكيه للدور الخليجي في الوضع
العراقي
الحالي خلف ابواب الموصد في فينا التقى
وزير الخارجيه الايراني مع ويليام برنز
نائب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وكاثرين
اشتون مسؤوله السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قبيل بدء مفاوضات حول ملف ايران
النووي لبحث الوضع المستجد في العراق
انعقاد الاجتماع يشير الى رغبه غربيه في
التنسيق مع ايران في العراق الى اي مد
يمكن ان يمضي هذا التنسيق هذا ما لم تجب
عنه التصريحات الامريكيه حتى الان وزير
الخارجيه جون كيري لم يؤكد امكانيه
التعاون عسكريا مع ايران لكنه ترك الباب
مفتوحا في الوقت الراهن اعتقد اننا نحتاج
ان نمضي خطوه خطوه لكنني لا استبعد اي شيء
بناء يمكن ان يحقق الاستقرار واحترام
الدستور واحترام قدره الشعب العراقي على
تشكيل حكومه تمثل مصالحه وليس مصلحه طائفه
على حساب طائفه اخرى اشار كيري في
تصريحاته الاخيره الى امكانيه لعب ايران
لدور ما لدفع الحكومه العراقيه الى اتخاذ
خطوات تبعدها عن الطائفيه ما هو الثمن
الذي يمكن ان تحصل عليه ايران مقابل هذا
الدور المحتم او المطلوب امريكيا وهل
سيكون هذا الثمن على حساب دول المنطقه
فدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي التي لم تعبر
حتى الان عن موقف جماعي وموحد مما يجري في
العراق لن تستفيد بالتاكيد من تعاون
امريكي ايراني في العراق وبعيدا عن هذه
التساؤلات يبقى من غير المضمون ان تلعب
ايران دورا يبعد الحكومه العراقيه عن
الطائفيه لديهم اجنده مؤيده للشيعه وتطرف
لقد ق يون سنوات وهم يحاولون زعزعه
استقرار العراق خلال الوجود العسكري
الامريكي لم يؤيدوا ابدا حكومه متعدده
الطوائف في العراق لقد مول الايرانيون
ميليشيات منعت خروج العراق من دائره العنف
يبدو ان طهران ترى ان من مصلحتها ان تتحرك
واشنطن للتصدي للوضع في العراق وتستحل ان
يكون ذلك بالتنسيق معها كما ان واشنطن ترى
ان ايران يمكن ان تلعب دورا وكلاهما يرى
ان ذلك سيحقق مصلحه
لكن يبقى السؤال على حساب
من معنا في هذه الحلقه من واشنطن باتريك
كلاوسن مدير قسم الابحاث في معهد واشنطن
لدراسات الشرق الادنى وعبر الهاتف من
العاصمه التشيكيه براج الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السعودي حسين شبكشي ونامل ان ينضم
الينا بعد قليل الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه من طهران امير
الموسوي نرحب بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا من
واشنطن والسيد
كلاوسن هل هل اقدمت واشنطن على هل اقدمت
واشنطن على هذه الخطوه المتعلقه
ب التنسيق والتعاون مع
ايران
بتجاهل لحلفائها في دول الخليج
العربيه الحكومه الامريكيه كانت مهتمه
بالتعاون مع الحكومه ايرانيه بشان
الاستقرار في العراق لعديد من الاعوام
الان ولقد كان هناك عدد من الاوقات حيث
كانت الولايات المتحده والسفير الايراني
التقوا والسفراء التقوا هناك بالتعاون مع
الحكومه وبشان العراق على مدى اعوام لكن
للاسف الحكومه الايرانيه
وبالتزامن قدمت بعض الدعم لحكومه المالكي
والكثير من الدعم للمت
من الشيعه الميليشيات اذا فكان هذا حوارا
صعبا وشاقا وصعب على واشنطن ان تجد سبيلا
لجعل ايران تتابع
كلامها الطيب ولكن علاقات واشنطن ودول
الخليج تتمحور على بسط الاستقرار وواشنطن
تحاول ان تجعل ايران ترتقي الى كلماتها
التي تدعو الى بسط الاستقرار والتي قدمت
هذه الكلمات في السابق ومع ذلك هناك احساس
وهنا اسال السيد حسين الشبكشي هناك احساس
لدى المراقبين على الاقل بان هناك نوع من
الاهمال او التهميش او حتى الاحتقار وفق
تعبير البعض ل دول الخليج العربيه من قبل
واشنطن وهي تتحرك كل هذه التحركات في
الايام
الماضيه ليس جديدا الموضوع تصاعدي وتراكمي
اعتقد منذ القيام بالحراك الامريكي وغزو
العراق من قبل اداره بوش السابقه وامريكا
في طرف من المحافظين الجدد اختار التعاون
مع
ايران وايران كانت جزء من هذه العمليه
الخاصه بغزو العراق معروف هذا الشيء وكان
هناك يحيط بجورج بوش مجموعه من المتعاطفين
مع الشان الايراني وخصوصا مع بول ولفو ود
مجله فورين بولس النافذه والمهمه حددت ذلك
الامر ان امريكا اختارت ان يكون حليف
الرئيسيين في منطقه الشرق الاوسط اسرائيل
وايران وهما بالمناسبه حليفين دينيين
واحده دوله تقول عن نفسها انها يهوديه
بشكل حصري الجوش ستيت اكسوفل والثانيه هي
دوله طائفيه فمن نصوص ترشيح الرئاسه ان
يكون مسلم
وشيعي فامريكا اخذت خطوه غير مسبوقه من
قبل ان تتعاون مع انظمه متطرفه جدا ومذهب
ودينيه حصريا في منطقه ملته اصلا وهذه
رساله خطيره جدا ابعد من ان نختار يعني
ونبحث في من هي اختارت ولكن ننظر الى معنى
الاختيار وهو معنى خطير في منطقه متاجج
عنصريا وطائفيا وثنيا وعرقيا فبالتالي
المنطقه مرشحه للمزيد من التصعيد وهو
المشهد الذي نراه ايران لانه هاتان
الدولتان كنموذج وجود كنموذج وجود يحتاجان
لامثله اخرى لوجود مثلها حتى لا تكون
المثالين الشاذين في المنطقه هذه هي
المساله المهمه ج نعم اذا اردنا ان نعمق
اكثر موضوع منا هذا الاختيار الذي اشرت
اليه السيد شبكشي نسال ضيفنا من طهران
الذي انضم الينا امير موسوي عما اذا كان
هناك في
طهران لنقل نوع من الانتشاء بان الولايات
المتحده اصبحت
تتعامل مضطره او راغبه مع طهران على حساب
حلفاء قدماء مثل السعوديه او قطر او غيرها
من دول الخليج
العربيه
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا اعتقد ان
الاداره الامريكيه تلعب على الحبلين يعني
من جانب تريد ارضاء ايران وهي تعرف الدور
الايراني والثقل الاستراتيجي الاقليمي
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه ومن جانب
ان تحاول تجييش الاوضاع في المنطقه وخاصه
في منطقه الخليج الفارسي للاسف الشديد بعض
الدول الخليجيه ما زالت تنجرف وراء هذا
المخطط يعني الان دخول السعوديه والبحرين
بصوره مباشره على الخط العراقي والازمه
العراقيه ودعم الارهابيين في في العراق
وكذلك جعل او تصوير هؤلاء بانهم ثوار انا
اعتقد هذا استدراج لهذه الدول يعني ربما
هذه الامور تتكرر في بلدانهم لاحقا
ويحرجون في المستقبل لانهم يصورون
الارهابيين والتكفيريين والمسلحين بانهم
ثوار فماذا سيعملون في ذلك الوقت فلذا انا
اعتقد انها مؤامره خطيره واستدراج خطير
للاسف الشديد بعض الدول الخليجيه لا تنتبه
الى هذا الامر وتنجرف عاده بسبب التراكمات
التاريخيه وربما ممكن ان نقول هناك نوع من
الحقد على بعض الوضع على الوضع في العراق
ولا ننسى ان السعوديه تجاهلت التجربه
السياسيه الجديده في العراق وهي التي
ساعدت وبعد ومعها بعض الدول الخليجيه
الاخرى ساعدت على اسقاط النظام السابق
نظام صدام حسين من من خلال وضع كل
الامكانيات تحت تصرف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من خلال دخول الجيوش الغربيه وا
الجيوش الغازيه الى العراق من خلال هذه
الدول فلذا اعتقد الان التعاطف مع حزب
البعث او حركه النقشبنديه برئاسه عزه
الدوري مع هذه الحركه التي في الحقيقه
تمثل نظام سابق دخل الكويت واحتل دوله
خليجيه هذا يدل على انهم لديهم يعني نوع
من الازدواجيه في المعايير وانا اعتقد ان
هذه التجربه تجربه سيئه لانه في الحقيقه
سنرى في المستقبل القريب هناك صوره جديده
للعراق هناك وحده طيبه وجميله من السنه
والشيعه والعرب والاكراد لكن بصوره جديده
وبصوره واقعيه لانه في الحقيقه على كل في
انتظار هذه الصوره الصوره الجميله
والجديده الان تبدو تبدو بعيده على كل في
في كل الاحوال الان ولهذا نسال السيد
باتريك كلاوسن في في واشنطن عما اذا كان
هناك هناك وعي في واشنطن بان هناك الان
انقسام حاد الحلفاء القدامى ان صح
التعبير دول الخليج العربيه لديها تقدير
معين وان كانت متفاوت وهناك ايران وهي عدو
قديم ولكنه الان في هذه المرحله يوجد
تناغم بينه وبين الولايات المتحده كيف
يمكن لواشنطن ان تتعامل مع هذا الوضع
الجديد
واشنطن
تعمل مع مجلس التعاون الخليجي ودوله
لتقول بان مجموعه داعش تهدد كما انها تهدد
اي طرف اخر وهذه مجموعه تقوم بالتفجيرات
في بلادكم وليس من صالحكم بالتالي ان تروا
هذه المجموعه تنجح اذا دعونا نعمل معا
ونتعاون لنح السلطات في بغداد لكي تقوم
بالاصلاح
كما طلبت دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ولكن
علينا ان نحث بغداد من خلال ان نقدم لهم
الدعم والمساعده
وللاسف دول الخليج ركزت فقط على انتقادها
ولم تكن مستعده لتقدم المساعده اذا ما تمت
الاصلاحات في بغداد واشنطن تريد ان ترى
الاصلاحات تتم في بغداد وحكومه جام
في العراق ولهذا الغرض فانها مستعده للعمل
مع ايران اذا ما كانت ايران
صادقه في تعزيز هذا النوع من الحكومه
المنفتحه كما انها تحث السعوديه ودول مجلس
التعاون الاخرى لتحث على هذا النوع من
الحكومه الجامعه في العراق من خلال ما
يجري ولكن دول الخليج يجب ان تقول انها
مستعده لتساعد العراق اذا ما سار في هذا
المسار
ولكن اذا اخذنا حتى بهذا التحليل سيد حسن
شوبك لماذا برايك لم تكلف واشنطن نفسها
حتى عناء حركه رمزيه كالاتصال هاتفيا باحد
القاده الخليجيين او ارسال مبعوث للاطلاع
على وجهه النظر الخليجيه مما يجري في
العراق ومحاوله التنسيق على الاقل بشكل
متوازي مع طهران ومع دول الخليج العربيه
لانه الموضوع حسم سيدي الكريم ا ايران
واسرائيل هم الحليفان الاستراتيجيين
الرئيسيان الان في المنطقه حتى سقور الحزب
الجمهوري الذين كانوا دائما يشنون هجمات
ضد
النظام الايراني وفي انقسام كبير بين اهم
قطبين فيها بين لينزي جراهم وجون مكين
لينزي راهام اصبح الان يمكيج او يجمل
التعاون والمباحثات مع ايران ويعتبرها
شبيهه بما حدث في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
عندما تباحث الحلفاء مع جوزف ستلين رئيس
الاتحاد السوفيتي وقتها فحتى الانشقاق في
صقور الحزب الجمهوري اصبح واردا وهناك
قناعه كامله ان ايران واسرائيل هما
الحليفين الوحيدين في المنطقه لانه ايران
جزء من الادوات الناعمه والغير ناعمه طبعا
المدمره في المنطقه التي كانت تستخدمها
بامتياز هي عولمه الارهاب صدرت حزب الله
باشكال القبيحه في مختلف الانحاء حزب الله
الحجاز وحزب الله البحرين وحزب الله
العراق وحزب الله لبنان وحزب حب الله في
اليمن وحزب الله طبعا في نيجيريا
واحتضنت قيادات القاعده
وساعدت على تصدير رؤوس القيادات الموجوده
في داعش من السجون السوريه عندما كانت
تتحرش بالمالكي قبل اندلاع الثوره السوريه
كل ذلك كان يتم با ايجاد امر واقع جديد
على الارض ان ايران ممكن ان تشعلل المنطقه
وايران ممكن ان تهدئ المنطقه فبالتالي
الامريكان حرصوا ان يكتفوا ب النزيف الذي
حدث لجنوده واضطروا الان يتعاملوا معان
ومع اسرائيل باعتبارهم القوتين الدينين
الوحيدتين في المنطقه التان ممكن ان تفهم
الوضع الجاري وطبعا هذه نظره قاصره جدا
سيدفع العالم كله ثمنها لاحقا بعد ذلك نعم
ولكن يبقى التحدي الابرز هو مدى توافق دول
اليج العربيه على موقف موحد او على الاقل
على حد ادنى من التنسيق في المقاربه تجاه
ما يجري في العراق نعود الى هذه النقطه
تحديدا بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد الاتجاه
الامريكي المتزايد للتعاون مع ايران في
العراق ورؤيه دول الخليج العربيه لهذه
الازمه سيد امير موسوي اشرت قبل قليل الى
السعوديه والبحرين بماربه نقديه ولكن هل
طهران تنظر الان على الاقل الى دول الخليج
العربيه نظره مختلفه عن السابق لان مثلا
عندما يتصل وزير الخارجيه ال الاماراتي
عبد الله بن زايد
بنظيره العراقي ويعرب له عن تاييده
للحكومه العراقيه ومقاومه الارهاب ورفض
الارهاب والتاكيد على استقرار العراق هل
هناك بتقديرك هذا يجعل الامر مختلف الان
بالنسبه لايران في نظرتها لدول الخليج
العربيه ومدى تلاحم
مواقفها يعني الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه تسعى في ان تنقل الصوره
الحقيقيه الى بعض القاده في الدول
الخليجيه للاسف الشديد هناك بعض السياسات
الانتحاريه لهذه الدول ونرى ان مثلا وزيره
الناطقه باسم الحكومه البحرينيه تعلن ان
ما حصل في العراق هو ثوره بينما هي ترى
كيف ياتون هؤلاء باجرام وبمذاق وبتدبير
البنى التحتيه وسرقه اموال الناس وايذائهم
في كل مكان على اي حال هذه الرؤيه
الانتحاريه انا اعتقد هذه مرفوضه اقليميا
ودوليا اصبحت اليوم المنطق القوي المستدل
والذي مبني على
اسس صحيحه هو الذي مقبوله الان في هذا
الوضع الجاري ايران حاولت التواصل مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وراينا نائب
وزير الخارجيه التقى ب ولي العهد السعودي
وكذلك نائب وزير الخارجيه السعودي في
القاهره وهناك اتصالات مستمره لكن على ما
يبدو هناك ما زالت بعض الصقور في الرياض
تحاول قبل
ال المفاوضات التي ستجري ربما بين الرياض
وطهران لاحقا على مستويات اعلى تحاول هذه
الصقور ان تربح ورقه ورقه ما في المنطقه
لانها في الحقيقه خسرت كل الاوراق ونرى
التجربه يريدون اعادتها في العراق بعدما
فشلوا في سوريا وبعدما تحققت الانتصارات
في سوريا وفاز الرئيس بشار الاسد باغلبيه
ساحقه في الانتخابات الاخيره يريدون خلط
الاوراق في العراق و تدمير النتائج
الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي جرت في العراق
فلذا نعتقد ان هذا الامر سيفشل كذلك لان
ايران لديها تصور واضح ولديها تنسيق على
اعلى المستويات مع الحكومه الشرعيه في في
العراق ولذا لا تحتاج الى التنسيق مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انا لا اعرف
لماذا الامريكان يتدخلوا في يدخلوا ويقحم
انفسهم في الوسط هناك تنسيق كامل الان بين
بغداد وطهران على مستوى الاستشارات واعتقد
اذا ما طلبت الحكومه العراقيه معد امير
موسوي هناك من يرى حتى هناك من يرى حتى
اعمق من مجرد التنسيق هناك من يعتبر الان
العراق كاملا تقريبا خاضع
لهيمنجواي نريد ان نسمع من سيد حسين
شبكشي التعليق على هذا الموقف خاصه فيما
يتعلق ب اعتبار وجود سقور في في الرياض
ارجوك ايضا ان ان تدلي بدلوك فيما يتعلق
بالى اي مدى تفكك ان صح التعبير المواقف
الخليجيه مما يجري الان من
العراق مما يجري في العراق سيؤثر بطبيعه
الحال على القدره على التاثير في هذه
الاحداث بس عندي تعليق سريع انا اهنئ
الاستاذ امير الموسوي على اجادته للغه
العربيه بس واضح انه مفهوم اللغه العربيه
م تلف عني انا لانه الانتخابات اللي حصلت
في سوريا هذه مهزله وليست انتخابات ما
علينا لكن نرجع لسؤالك ونوضح انه الان
طبعا الوضع في العراق اصبح هناك هيمنه
كامله من قبل المخابرات الايرانيه على
المالكي
وزمرته التي تحكم طبعا لا يمكن الاون حتى
عندنا مسعود برزاني اليوم تحدث بوضوح شديد
جدا وهو من اهم اقطاب الحكم في العراق
اليوم وطال طلب استقاله المالكي لانه لم
يعد يمثل الشعب ككل ولم يعد يمثل
العراقيين ككل الحديث الان من داخل العراق
هناك عشائر تتحدث هناك مناطق تتحدث وهناك
اقاليم تتحدث وتعرب بصريح العباره عن
رفضها لاستمرار
هيمنه المالكي بالشكل الذي قام عليه بطائف
قبيحه باجرام فضيع بحق الشعب وهذه المساله
اصبح لها صدى دولي من وزاره الخارجيه
البريطانيه وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ولم
يعد الامر شاء الخليجي فقط طبعا ابعاد هذه
المساله على الوضع الامني الخليجي مهمه
جدا وعلى الوضع العربي كذلك المساله تخطط
حدود الخليج واصبحت شان عربي في يتحدثون
في هذا الامر في الاردن وفي المغرب وفي
الجزائر وفي تونس وفي مصر وفي اليمن
المساله خرجت عن طوق محدود وطبعا الهمجيه
التي تحكم بها الامور في سوريا من قبل
نظام غاشم هي نفس المساله التي تحكم بها
الامور في العراق وال والمسؤول عن هذه
المساله هو اجهزه الاستخبارات الايرانيه
التي تدعم هذان النظامان وتؤجج المنطقه
ككل وطبعا نعتبر في دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وفي اكثر الدول العربيه ان هذا
تحديدا صريحا للامن العربي ككل مسؤول عنه
النظام الايراني وبالتالي من المطلوب ان
تتعامل دول الخليج بصوت موحد اعتقد طبعا
هناك فروقات النغمه الكويتيه غير النغمه
الاماراتيه غير النغمه القطريه في هذه
المساله ولكن داخليا الجميع يعي تماما ان
هناك كره لهب تتدحرج الى الخليج ككل
وترمى من قبل الايرانيين على هذه المنطقه
نعم اذا اخذنا مختلف النغمات نسال سيد
باتريك كلاوسن وجود نغمات خليجيه مختلفه
النغمه السعوديه الان غير النغمه
الاماراتيه النغمه القطريه اقرب للنغمه
السعوديه هل واشنطن تشعر بالارتياح ان
هناك اطراف خليجيه الان الامارات مثلا على
سبيل المثال هي اقرب للتصور الامريكي من
بقيه الدول مثل
السعوديه هناك بعض التوترات في العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه فالسعوديه هي اكثر
تشكك من الحكومه في ايران بينما
واشنطن تامل بان المالك يمكن اقناعه
بتغيير ذلك هناك الكثير من الاوقات في
العلاقات التاريخيه بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والسعوديه اظهرت خلافات بين
البلدين رغم ذلك مازال يتعاونان عن كثب
بشان القضايا التي بينهما قضايا
استراتيجيه مهمه بما في ذلك هزيمه القاعده
وايضا التخلص من المجموعات العنف
الارهابيه التي تهدد السعوديه كما هي تهدد
الولايات المتحده لذلك تامل واشنطن ان
تستطيع العمل مع المملكه السعوديه لعزل و
هزيمه المجموعات المسلحه المتطرفه التي
كانت نشطه في شمال العراق في ذات الوقت
الولايات المتحده تحث بغداد على ان تعالج
المظالم المشروعه التي هي لدى السكان
السنه في شمال العراق وهذا امر سوف يساعد
على تحسين العلاقات السعوديه العراقيه
ايضا سيد كلاوسن في تصريح اخير لويليام
كوين وزير الدفاع الامريكي سابق يتحدث عن
ضروره وضع طوق من النار هكذا سماه طوق من
النار حول حلفائنا في المنطقه وهذا يتضمن
الاردن
ودول الخليج هل تعتقد بان واشنطن قادره
على ذلك في المرحله
المقبله ان الدفاع عن هذه البلاد يعتمد
كثيرا على حكومات هذه البلاد وما واشنطن
تستطيع فعله ان تقدم بعض المساعده والدعم
ولكن بالتاكيد
حكومات كالتي في السعوديه والاردن هي
حكومات قويه وتحظى بالدعم من الشعب ولها
سبل للدفاع عن نفسها والولايات المتحده
ستكون تتشاطر معهم المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه بشان المخاطر الاتيه من هذه
المجموعات العنفه المتطرفه وللعمل معا
وانا واثق بانه يمكن ان نفعل الكثير لعزل
هذه المجموعات المتطرفه العنف وسينجح هذا
فقط في المجالات التي لا تكون الحكومه
تبلي بلاء حسنا كما هو الحال في سوريا وفي
شمال العراق وحكومه المالكي
التي لم تستمع ولم تنصت الى المظالم من
السنه شكرا جزيلا لك سيد باتريك كلاوسن
مدير قسم الابحاث في مع واشنطن لدراسات
الشرق الادنى شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من طهران
امير الموسوي الخبير في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا
من براغ الكاتب والباحث السياسي السعودي
حسين شبكشي بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه
دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء